hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about basic sword
theory so um
this stuff generally tends to get in the
way a lot of the practice and so there's
there's a lot of you know real theorists
out there
so i'm going to try to outline some
theory for you guys that's really basic
and common sense and should help clarify
a lot of the stuff you see people doing
with swords
and this stuff comes from a bunch of
historical research i've done and then
also practical experience
doing a lot of sword sparring and
playing with swords so i'm going to give
you some basic outlines of important
things you need to think about and
what's happening in sword fighting so
i'm going to get josh out here we're
going to go to work josh
all right so let's talk about basic
sword theory
and i'm not going to load you down with
a bunch of weird historical references
or give you any kind of dogmatic
approach i'm basically just going to
explain how i think about sword fighting
or honestly any kind of weapon on weapon
situation
and and what's going on with that and i
think i can make it real simple for you
all right so
when you're fighting another person with
a weapon so we're having some kind of
dueling situation even if it's for a
split second so remember aikido is not
about a dueling situation it's about
some kind of situation where i
preferably just like to not be there or
not dealing with this guy or de-escalate
in some kind of way that's what i want
but we're in a dueling situation at
least for a split second what's
happening in that dueling situation all
right now if josh is just on guard here
okay and i just say i want to hit him
that's it right my only thought is i
want to hit him if i just came in like
this he's going to hit me in return
right so that's my inherent first
problem is i come in there and i get
this guy and he's going to get me in
return right so if this guy does not
care about himself that's what he's
going to do
okay now that is also always balanced by
the fact
that i can make the assumption generally
that he's more interested in protecting
himself than he is and hurting me now i
i'm sure he's interested in hurting me
but secondary to protecting himself so i
often can get away with attacking on
this line because he's probably going to
remove his weapon to defend himself
right so so that kind of thing happens
all right now
both of those situations for me as a
weapon user against this guy are bad
situations one i get hurt in so that's
no good for me and two i have an
unsuccessful attack because he owns the
center line right so like right now he
owns i own mine too but he owns his over
in his space so it means if i attempt to
attack in there he's either going to hit
me
or he's going to defend what i'm
throwing my shot into so i don't want
either one of those two things to happen
so i'm always going to find a way to
attack him that doesn't involve that so
i want to find some kind of awesome way
to attack him that doesn't involve that
so what can i do well i could either
wait for him to do something right so he
could like wind up his sword or
something ah now his swords over there
this might be an ideal time to attack
okay i could move myself to a better
place so if i moved over here and he
didn't move his defense over here then
this is good this is the kind of kind of
way i could attack him or i could remove
whatever is defending him from the space
right so i can somehow move that out
these are the basic ways i'm going to
set up my initial attack and if i'm
doing anything with my initial attack
other than some some way to break down
his defenses i'm not doing my job okay
now there's all kinds of things i could
shout at this guy or kick dirt in his
face who knows there's all kinds of ways
i could possibly do it but in general
i'm going to break it down to either i'm
going to change the the line
i'm going to remove his weapon myself or
i'm going to wait for him to remove his
weapon and that's when i'm going to
attack so those are the moments that i'm
looking to attack right so that's that's
what i'm looking for all right now
inherently every time i attack this guy
there's the possibility he's gonna
attack me back if we have similar
weapons so right now we have
the same weapon right so the same basic
length weapon we're about the same size
so this means whenever i touch josh he
can touch me back right he can always
touch me back when i'm touching him so
that means that if he has at least a
split second before he dies or gets
blown away or cut in half or whatever i
do he's going to return shot on me
so that means every time i attack him
i'm also planning my defense in the
attack and if i'm not doing that then
i'm not preserving myself when i'm
attacking him so it means i have to
figure out some clever way that i'm
going to defend whatever it is he throws
next after i attack that doesn't mean
he's going to throw it just means that
i've got to be prepared for it there are
two major ways i'm going to do that one
is i'm going to try and land a shot that
is distanced in such a way that he
doesn't have an easy return to attack so
for example if i come out to a line like
this if he goes high to my head you see
my sword's in the way if he goes low to
my body the angle i've chosen is
protecting me from his sword so i can
distance myself use an angle to attack
in such a way that he can't immediately
easily return attack we're going to get
to what easily return attack means in a
second but that's one of the ways i'm
going to do it is i'm going to make an
angle in order to do that
okay so
other than distancing another tool i'm
going to use a lot is opposition and
opposition means that whenever i make an
attack my sword is immediately ready to
go into a defensive action
ideally i would like to always use my
sword in a way that it's already in a
defended action let me show you what i
mean with that with a thrust when i
drive my sword in with a thrust my
sword's already in contact with his
which means whatever he does with his
sword my sword can stick to it and gives
me instant opposition it can oppose his
sword
another real simple example of that is
if i was on this angular line here that
i was on before here and i'm at the
wrong distance so right now you can see
if he brings it in i'm at the wrong
distance okay however my action with the
sword is in the defense so notice that
as i'm hitting him my sword's driving
through to defend myself now even if i
if i went through his head cool that'd
be good so i cut him in half and he's
got enough brain power to attack me one
more time then i'm still going to get
through here but even if he doesn't i
don't drive through him my sword can
still be brought down to defend myself
so i always want to put my sword in a
position that it can defend me right
after so that means i wouldn't make
attacks like this for example okay i
wouldn't attack here now the reason is
if he goes to attack me
i can't easily bring my sword down here
to defend myself right because my body
is facing this way which means to defend
myself i gotta really turn it around
okay and we're gonna get to in one
second a really important thing as to
why that's really not practical at all
but just understand here this is a
difficult position for me to get around
to defend myself if i was going to
attack him on this line i would turn my
body this way now you see my sword
naturally cuts down so if i'm here i
wouldn't attack him this way hard to
defend what he's going to do next but if
i attack this way see i instantly have
that defense so i always want to when
making an attack have opposition
available to me which means i can bring
the sword in to defend myself right
after i attack because he's still going
to get an action i don't hit him with
the sword and he instantly dies probably
not usually anyways okay now
another important thing and i've talked
about this but this cannot be talked
about enough
is
always assume that he's at least going
to get an action for every action you
make and those actions are going to be
equal and this is what i mean if i get
to move my arm for an action like this
josh gets to move his arm for an action
okay so if he's paying attention equally
to what i'm doing we're both on the ball
if i move my arms josh can move his arms
right so if my idea was to somehow sneak
over here and get a high shot on josh he
can move his arms to get that same
defense okay now arms move very very
fast which means moving in here to
something like this is dangerous because
his arms are all that's needed to hit my
body there right real simple body action
all right now if i can give myself a
little more distancing okay and due to
the angles that i've taken here now his
arms can't traverse that distance so he
can't make it with his arms but he still
could make it with his body if he leans
forward with his foot there but there he
does it with his body okay so let's look
at that again he comes in bang he's
easily able to whack so he can come in
here and you see he can hit my body in
there right so all he's doing is having
to lean forward just a little bit and he
does that but because we're action for
action when he moves his body in i can
move my body out so remember again
action for action if he moves his body i
get to move my body if i move my body he
gets to move his body the same is true
of feet and feet are the slowest meaning
that if i'm coming to attack this guy
every time i step he's going to also
have the opportunity to step so if i
come in at that angle and he sees me
take a step he can always just step out
of the way of that angle i'm making
right so i step in to get him he can
always step out so this is always the
trade that you need to understand assume
he's at least as capable as you are he's
paying as much attention as you are and
is roughly as skilled as fast or has as
much uh physical ability as you do and
then in that say if i make a hand action
he gets to make a hand action if i make
a body action he gets to make body
action and foot for foot now if i can
skew those timings in such a way to help
me meaning he would have to take a
footstep for my hand action i'm in a
winning position the same is true though
for him if i'm attacking so if i attack
this guy and the only way to get out of
there is to take a step when he comes to
attack me he's going to get me every
time because all he has to do is move
his arms the fastest moving thing and i
got to move my feet the slowest moving
thing he's going to get me every time
now when we're doing stop start action
or or learning a form or something
that's not true because everything's
broken up in time and so you don't
inherently get those ideas that those
always an action for an action
okay now advanced swordsmanship gets
into the ideas of like how to trick his
mind how to play with his uh ideas of
what's going on how to trick him into
distances so all these are really useful
tools but basic swordsmanship you just
need to understand these ideas right and
it's that if i'm attacking him i need to
attack in a way that he doesn't
inherently defend because the worst
thing that would happen is i die for
that right so if we're here and i just
march in on the line worst thing is i
die oh that's really bad okay second
worst thing is he defends and i lose an
action for that right so and loss of
action we'll talk about that in another
video that gets into more advanced
swordsmanship but that's bad to lose
actions right okay so i've got to find a
way to get to this guy right i'm either
going to remove a sword i'm going to
remove myself to a new line or i'm going
to wait for him to do something and i'm
going to attack in those times so that's
what i'm looking for first and foremost
okay then when i make my attack i always
need to make my attack in a way that i'm
inherently defended one great way i can
do that is through distancing here i can
hit him and he can't counter hit me back
which is what we're looking for okay or
also i should and also i should always
have opposition meaning that my sword's
instantly ready to go so if i'm here and
he comes to attack me i can instantly
move my sword where i need to move my
sword to defend myself and that's all
hinged on the idea of action for action
meaning if i get an action he gets an
action or if he gets an action i do and
the timings of those actions are hands
move the fastest bodies the second
fastest and feet the slowest and so i'm
always trying to skew those factors in
my to my advantage and take away from
him and that's how i stack the
foundation of winning some kind of
dueling sword situation or stick or
whatever situation you're talking about
i'm christopher hine this is the
fundamentals of sword theory
[Music]
you